SPEAKER_00(Sarah): Good morning everyone, lets get started with the projet review.
SPEAKER_01(Tom): Thanks sarah. So, uh, the migration to the new Kubernetis cluster is basically done.
SPEAKER_01(Tom): We still have, you know, two servises that needs to be moved before friday.
SPEAKER_00(Sarah): OK. And what about the data base backups, are they runing on the new setup?
SPEAKER_01(Tom): Yes, the backups run every night at two AM, and we tested the restore prosedure yesterday.
SPEAKER_02(Priya): Quick question — did we updated the runbook for the on call team?
SPEAKER_01(Tom): Uh, not yet, I will do it this afternoon and share it on the wikki.
SPEAKER_00(Sarah): Perfect. Priya, any news on the Grafanna dashboards for the new cluster?
SPEAKER_02(Priya): Yes, the dashboards are ready, I just need to add the alerting rules for the disk usage.
SPEAKER_00(Sarah): Great. Lets meet again thursday to check the last two servises, ok?
SPEAKER_01(Tom): Works for me. I'll send the invite after this call.
SPEAKER_00(Sarah): Thanks everyone, have a good day.